it's so clear that the republicans they
have a strategy and they're
executing their strategy it is
suppressing the votes
of voters of color and young people who
turned out for joe biden
and flipped georgia and arizona and who
according to data less likely to vote
for republicans so
what's the democrat strategy
look we believe in fighting fair and
having laws in place that make it easier
for people to vote right syria that's
the whole point of a democracy
not to think well the only way i can win
is if i can
suppress in ways that are inconsistent
with the core values of our democracy
your right to vote and you're right in a
very diabolical way
particularly across the south we are
seeing increasing numbers of legislators
who did not like the outcome of the
election which was fair and square
don't listen to me listen to president
trump's former attorney general who said
it was all nonsense to think that the
election wasn't on the up and up
so they say okay well if we can't win
fair and square let's see what we can do
to suppress the vote there are 48 states
where republicans in their legislatures
are trying to make it harder to vote
in the absence of vote fraud and it is
clearly an intent to discourage black
and brown
people from being able to vote and young
people too for that matter
and the only thing that stands in the
way of that happening
is us the american people which is why
we have to speak out loud and clearly on
this issue
voting rights was a critical issue going
back to 2013 when the shelby decision
happened
and that was during the obama
administration can you talk about the
ways attorney general eric holder who
was included in that conversation
the ways a.g holder and your
administration in particular work to
protect voting rights because
as soon as that shelby decision was
handed down the doj
they went to work what did they do
well we tried very hard state by state
to try to protect
um the the ability for local uh
folks who are responsible for the
elections to have fair and open
elections
and that was much harder after shelby
shelby
required the burden of proof to be on
them to say okay we are
operating a fair election it shifted
when that protection was gutted from the
voting rights act and we tried
to get congress the republicans in
congress to be specific
to reauthorize it because what the
supreme court said is
we're not going to uphold it but go back
to congress that's your remedy
and get them to do so and the fact that
since that time
not only have the republicans in
congress not move forward with a
reauthorization
but as i said state by state they have
been trying to pass laws to suppress the
vote and on top of that
they are giving voice to the nonsense
they're trying to bamboozle the american
people
into thinking that there was something
unfair
about the last election and that is
harmful for
to our democracy no matter who's in
office
we hold ourselves out selena around the
world
as a country that has a strong democracy
and so if we are supporting
insurrections and saying that they're
just like your average tour
of the capital if we are condoning those
who
question the election those who
criticize the vice president of the
united states for certifying the
election
something he just spoke out and said he
had no choice to do then we are in
trouble and so yes during president
obama's time in office
eric holder was a leader in this effort
um trying to ensure that he protected
the rights
of citizens and i'm heartened to see
that merrick garner garland
uh the attorney general today is has
filed a lawsuit
against the state of georgia and saying
that the laws that they passed
are unconstitutional and that's what we
are going to have to do state by state
by state
but i also want to just say let's just
not leave it to the attorney generals
to fight on our behalf we have to add
our voices to the equation and we have
to vote
out of office people who are doing these
dastardly deeds
it feels like and the word bamboozled is
under underutilized frankly i think um
it is a very good word and i feel like
in a lot of ways
you know when you when you put it that
way it just
it it's so applicable here because we
all want a democracy like i don't care
what side of the political
aisle you're on or what you care about
in terms of tax cuts like what the
tax rate you prefer is that's not the
point the point is is that
you want it to be fair for everybody and
so many
these laws are going into place and
they're already in place so at this
point it's a it's a little bit about
mitigating the damage
what are some of the ways that can be
done um is it is it just
the voters at home calling congress
until
they finally pick up um to ensure that
there's federal legislation as soon as
possible or are there other things that
biden can do well as we spoke his
attorney general
on his own independently is challenging
laws
uh on the basis of them being
unconstitutional
inconsistent with the voting rights act
uh those laws that are suppressing the
vote
look just take georgia they're making it
harder for people to vote
absentee they're they're saying it's a
it's a crime if you take
food or drinks to somebody who's
standing in line come on now
we're standing in line you don't think
that somebody should be able to bring us
food or water particularly
in a state where we know that there are
long lines and people have to wait for
hours to vote
and so we need our justice department
doing exactly what attorney general
merrick garland is doing
we need to have people who are voting
and showing up at the polls
in record numbers and so if i'm
out there and i'm hearing this story
that somebody's trying to
bamboozle me and tell me that the
election is unfair and i
know that that's not true and i know
that they're trying to suppress my vote
i'm going to stand in line and be even
more determined to vote
i'm going to show up and make sure my
vote counts because
i know that i stand on the shoulders of
people who fought and
sacrificed greatly for me to have that
right to vote
i'm not going to let any legislator take
it away from me so we should be
outraged and we should be more
determined than ever no matter what
obstacles they put in our way
to show up and vote and we need to make
sure that we have an administration
which we are fortunate enough to have
right now
with president biden and his attorney
general who are going to fight those
laws state by state by state
if they deem them to be unconstitutional
as many of them are
i want to turn now to the insurrection
on january 6
president obama spoke at an event today
about
that the attack on the capital and the
potential for a repeat
so let's take a listen
the guard rails i thought were in place
around
many of our democratic institutions uh
really depend on the two parties
agreeing to those ground rules those
guard rails and that one of them right
now
doesn't seem as committed to him
as in previous generations that worries
me
uh and i think we should all be worried
i mean i think there's sort of
proverbial guardrails and real
guardrails that
we all were surprised uh weren't as firm
as we thought
at this rate how much democracy is at
risk
how much is democracy at risks oh sorry
julian i think i think we are at a
precipice here
when the sitting president of the united
states
tells people that the election was
unfair even though his own
administration
from the fbi to homeland security to the
justice department tells him that's not
true
yet he perpetuates this farce that it
was a
that it was an election that was stolen
from him when he tells his supporters
that they should take to the streets
and go and fight to defend his
presidency which he lost
and they respond in kind
and stormed the capital and then
the republicans decide that we shouldn't
investigate what happened and find
out who was behind it and we see
evidence that
some of them were complicit in that
attack and the very ones who said well
it was nothing other than an ordinary
tour we see photographs of them
barricaded in trying to protect
themselves
from this onslaught if that scene
happened in any other country around the
world
the united states would be the first to
point at finger and say
that is a threat to democracy and the
republicans who condone that
have to be held accountable and so we
need to get to the facts we have to have
transparency with the american people
and those guard rails are what protects
our democracy
and so if we let them just fall by the
wayside
then who are we who are we
it's a good question that i think folks
should uh
marinate on a little bit valerie jarrett
thank you as always for taking the time
to join me today and please stay safe
hi i'm zerlina maxwell thanks for
checking out our channel on youtube
you can see more from zerlina by
clicking any of the videos on this
screen
and make sure you subscribe below to
stay up to date on the day's biggest
stories
thanks for watching